يقال ان غلطه الشاطر بالف ونظام البنتاجون
المعروف باسم نظام الاتصالات الاستخباراتي
المشتركه العالميه كان الغلطه الاكبر في
قضيه تسريب 300 وثيقه عسكريه سريه
لم ينهي اعتقال الشاب جاك تشييرا للواحد
والعشرين عاما والمنحدر من عائله وطنيه
بامتياز لغز تسريب وثائق شديده الحساسيه
من داخل المنظومه الدفاعيه الامريكيه بل
اشعل وابلا من الاسئله والتشكيك في منظومه
تمنح جنديا بسيطا تصريح دخول واستخراج
معلومات حساسه تتسبب باحراج اقوى دوله في
العالم المالوف عن الجندي انه وطني
وكاثوليكي متدين مهتم بالاسلحه كما يدعي
اصدقائه وجيرانه تم التعبئته للخدمه
الفيدراليه الخليفه الماضي بعد ان تلقى
تدريبا للعمل في الحرس الوطني في قسم
انظمه النقل السيبراني قبلها وخلال فتره
كورونا اشترك الشاب مع عشرين اخرين جمعهم
الشغف بالاسلحه بانشاء مجموعه على منصه
ديسكورد
وما بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه بدات الشراء
بمشاركه مستندات سريه معبرا عن احباطه من
حصول معركه بين دولتين تجمعهما اشياء
مشتركه كما تذكر صحيفه الوشنطن بوست نقلا
عن صديق مقرب من تشيره
فالهدف من تسريب الوثائق وفقا لصديقه
تثقيف مجموعه وثقى بها بعيدا عن الدعايه
الاعلاميه دون ان يخطر بباله ان احدهم قد
يقوم بتسريبها خارج الخادم والاضرار
بالامن القومي يوما ما قد لا نعلم الكثير
عن هذا الشاب بعد لكنه هو من عرف بنفسه
على احد المواقع قائلا احذر الرجل الهادئ
فبينما يتحدث الاخرون هو يراقب وبينما
يتصرف الاخرون هو يخطط وعندما يسترحون
اخيرا يضرب كرم حناوي العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات